[Music]
fans of the band the Black Crowes
wondered if they'd ever witnessed this
again brothers Chris and rich Robinson
in harmony on stage how is this feeling
this event or may enrich being together
it's really nice
[Music]
after a brief acoustic tour they're
getting ready to take the Black Crowes
on the road again I think for rich and I
had to spend that time together you know
we sat on airplanes together we never
did that we did interviews we're doing
this you ever did these things together
before not really
a swaggering southern rock band the
Black Crowes broke out in the early 90s
older brother Chris the frontman rich
two years younger
the guitarist and principal songwriter
but the brothers fought bitterly and
after it all came apart in 2013 swore
they'd never even speak again when you
reconnected who called who we didn't
really call each we didn't see the first
time we saw each other was randomly
we're here in New York at the same hotel
how long had it been seven years did you
have to decide that you could live with
each other again I feel like the whole
of our existence we always just kind of
grabbed a hold of the Train just hopped
on it just kind of went with it yeah
there's just an understanding that Chris
and I've always had I mean you know
people have asked like did you guys make
the decision well Chris and I never sat
down at a table and let's start a band
and let's do this we just did it the
Robinsons were raised in suburban
Atlanta Chris was the expeditionary he
would go he'll take he would bring in
all the new stuff and I would listen
through the wall and then when he'd go
to school I would take the one that I
wanted to hear their debut album shake
your moneymaker released in 1990 shot
into the top ten shake your moneymaker
really was kind of like a rocket ship
for you guys wasn't it yeah yeah I mean
it changed everything
[Music]
the album went on to sell more than 5
million copies when we left home when
the record was coming out I mean and we
each had basically one carry-on bag I
had two shirts and a pair of cowboy
boots and you know 12 months later I go
you can buy homes and cars by 1991 they
were playing the Monsters of Rock tour
with Metallica and ac/dc
you may dig it later
that September they played before an
estimated audience of 1.6 million at a
Moscow airfield a month after the Soviet
coup that's where I first interviewed
Chris Robinson it's just a wild place
really wild I think it's their follow-up
album the southern harmony and musical
companion soared to number one but the
brothers became their own worst enemies
nothing could have stopped that band
except for that band said their former
drummer Steve Gorman who wrote in his
recent memoir hard to handle
I wanted to kill both of them rich and I
fought on stage you know fought at the
gigs we fought on the bus we fought in
the van we fought backstage but we never
fought while we were writing the songs
that's when reg and I were completely in
harmony about what we wanted to do you
know what did you fight so much I think
it's just a typical sort of brother
thing he can be aggressive and I can be
really passive aggressive you know what
I mean I mean we both have our own ways
of going about this and so the fights
were us trying to figure out or at least
me trying to figure out like who I was
and while Rich's like that I'm
completely out of my mind you know what
I mean I mean I'm out of my mind and
then you add drugs and alcohol into the
whole thing and I'm like really cooking
with gas at this
[Music]
the brothers both launched successful
solo careers but ultimately each found
something missing the reality is is like
we need each other to make that engine
go my ego right or wrong or whatever I
was kinda like I don't need him I can go
to sing me songs without him and see if
I can you know see what will happen
but you do need them I do how do you
know this is gonna work this time
you know musically it will always work
for a myriad of reasons we want this to
work we want this to work for us but we
want this to work for you know music and
for our history where we came from what
we're doing moving forward for rich in
hides who repair our relationship as
brothers and as a family it just so
happens that it's in the backdrop of
this music that we've created